hello and welcome to this video wife
white again okay so a Sicilian defense
yeah already doing very okay with my
keep it simple repertoire it's really no
reason to not play it oh wow
it's surprised
yeah I'm not unhappy about this sound as
always this hole on d5 that you can play
play for
loses a bit of time but that's really
not that's not the most processable I
can't wait here the only way for him to
avoid the bishop begins tonight scenario
and I was 98 and I can still just go to
e3 and be better I would be better
because the night is just a better piece
and sorry the bishop is just the better
piece so let's see what to do here
this has he fallen now on the cards I'd
see force but a bit annoying shouldn't
do that so let's stop see form
yeah it's a notoriously solid position
that guess but yeah okay so if I take a
drupe checks f5 and ready to jump to d5
if five is not not to move I'm extremely
happy with
it should also be fine without having to
move a five that looks ugly yeah maybe
maybe it's not a problem
I can tak Knight b6 and then put the
Knight to d5 just did it so it feels a
little bit simplistic maybe it's just
good young
and to d5 couldn't see for things like
that
he's still suffering a bit from that
Bishop and being a bad piece
hmm we're taking c5 and threatening
Knight f6 check what now
[Music]
ninety-seven hey I got something I can
still just take c5
yeah that looks bad for book
this is no good okay what does he go
into the moon the king Mary I wonder if
there is some idea with Bishop takes e5
in Quincy aid but my queen is covered on
c4 and it's not something that is really
worrisome I don't see
yeah this ending is not going to be much
fun for him
maybe let's prevent any f5 stuff now we
have four I've got all the time here
Knight f5 for doublet tech Lambert
going on here really still whether to
drive the Harley hmm
it's been cold that's a bit bit harsh
but it wasn't not the weather you you
would think people would bring out their
their shoppers but some people really
love to to ride the bike yeah it's sdsu
une idée aid me you cannot trade
he thinks he can trade really
yeah just run for the pawns going to win
them all
yeah technical technical game but all of
a sudden there was a pawn dropping yeah
this is just a position type that is
going to be eternally better for Wyatt
I'm I'm surprised that the engine
suggests c-form but thinking about it
it's not a bad choice see form in this
position in order to play this and still
a play for disadvantage and then the
Knight to g5 interesting alternative
sorry I played Luke d1 which is very
comparable I did not want to do that I
wanted to have the C 4 square for my
pieces yeah he is interesting I can take
on f6 just going to be extremely
extremely slow and if I have enough time
here to put the night here and Queen to
c4 and so on it's great it's just too
slow yeah this is why I went 92 and now
we had 98 and yeah we should take c7
suggested by the engine it's just a
gross strategic error that's it's a
completely ridiculous move yeah it's
just totally ridiculous you have to keep
your bishop in order to get something
going and yeah I'm just slightly better
forever basically
Lucas 794 multi-age take take
now f5 was the alternative that was the
other idea that is possible at the end I
went for Luke d1 which is maybe not as
strong f6 was a strange choice him I
thought you would take out and then go
from there b5 I did not really have on
the radar all that much
of course possible yeah that is okay for
black young he scared he's got the space
and I cannot go to d5 any chance oh that
was his opportunity and said he went f6
and this is now reared because I get
into this really great position on d5
and now it's actually a little bit
awkward already and you see that the
engine I'm not sure here you see the
Evalia 1 1 + form it's really awkward
and after Bishop d6 Quincy foyer
basically toast it was but we added here
that he decided to trade everything ok
now we see that Quincy aid was even
stronger but the ending is just to win
the night ending upon up when there's
just nothing special going on it's
usually a win or gives at least very
very good winning chances and here
strangely enough he traded of course 98
looks young look sick but they have to
do it and yeah I still need a little bit
of technical technical claim to win this
not even sure what I would have done
engine suggests g4
you know maybe whenever he goes g6 the
thing is let's say I do that whenever he
goes g6 and I'm travelling here then I'm
always looking at that weakness and
that's awkward him they have to go into
a passive different defense down for
example what the engine is giving here
is just completely completely lost it's
always tied to that and I'm going here
push the points just just winning yeah
ok thanks for watching